so I have a million questions for you
but first let me start by saying
congrats you're both so good in this I
know it's going to make at least 15 at
the box office let's see right exactly
25. but uh so this is a movie though
that I would imagine a lot of people
wanted to be a part of so ultimately
what did the both of you pay to be in it
uh truly uh I called uh I was not not I
wasn't up on the list I wasn't on the
list I wasn't listed adjacent
um and I knew I was like I'm not gonna
get it but I knew I had to at least make
a play for it because I was like I'll
just I'll be so mad at myself forever
from like I didn't even try to get you
know turned down
um and I I've called you know I couldn't
call Rob because
um but I you know I I finally got I knew
a guy who knew a guy and I just said can
I please come and talk to you can I just
can I just tell you what Ursula means to
me and then uh I never thought I would
get it so I I was not asked I begged to
do it and I'm so glad I did it worked
out yeah it worked out and every minute
was great uh for you same here I sent me
a text saying I would love to play King
Trident if there's such a thing as a
king Trader within this body's accent
and he was uh
yeah in the grocery store grocery store
shopping and said we were talking about
you and I said really and then my
daughter was there and he was so excited
and she said what's going on I may be in
The Little Mermaid and she said she was
seven are you not playing Ariel
it's been like I want to see that movie
so badly as him as her Ariel so we both
really wanted to be part of this I'm
just curious the the thing that really
struck me your performance is fantastic
sitting the performance fantastic
singing fantastic but the thing that got
me was the way the animators brought
Ursula to life so how many thank you
cards have you sent to CGI people uh
that's a long list did you sit through
the whole end of it how about the end of
that movie when that that scroll goes
and you see all those people and all
that amazing talent to make it to bridge
from what we did to what you see takes
so much work and they just made
everything better because there are
there's moments I did so much of it but
I'm like well I can only spin so far
because I'm not really an activist and I
can spin and then I'm I'm not there but
they have to get me to here and it was
done it was done so beautifully I
thought and like I I need to send I'm
gonna break both hands writing thank you
letters what is your favorite moment
from the original film and what is the
moment in this one that you just loved
it has to be hours now no it doesn't
have to be
um
oh there are many moments for me I mean
um under the scene this one I mean it's
the choreography that they've built
around that it's crazy I don't know how
they've done it and it's so big it's a
first it's it's it's something to stand
up and applaud and celebrate in the
movie theater but there are many moments
like that like so many Unfortunate Souls
the way she sings that song the whole
number it's crazy good I mean everything
I think you know what the first thing
that struck me first so beautiful and it
was like I I'm we're underwater like I
I'm not seeing any of the work which is
I think what you can always say when
everything's going right you're like I'm
not seeing any of the work I just feel
I feel the emotion I feel the story
which means everybody's doing like
bionically good work but Hallie coming
out in part of your world when she's
coming up and it's such a everyone knows
that song and everyone knows that mode
from the original but seeing her do it
with a modern young woman's gut in her
and realizing she's not just singing
about like I want to do different stuff
it was about like I am going to
determine my own life
and there was just moments when Hallie's
face was so like you felt her heart and
her courage and I thought this is such a
different way for so many people to see
a Disney princess and it's with this
determination and like you will not
assign me my life and I got so I got so
choked up and I was so proud of her but
like that's a big difference it's it's
not a whole new number it's not a whole
thing but like those little differences
that that Rob and John and Disney made
and Holly did and it's all through the
movie but those things making it
relevant to today meant so much to me
those were like really the the moments
that just like went right to my heart
Dune is one of my favorite films of the
last few years please just real quick
what was it like working on the sequel
amazing I mean what a another gift that
life bring bring to me and I I don't
know what I did to deserve that uh
you're really good
I mean
he's like Rob Marshall they are so
lovely human beings with such a creative
Mastermind behind that it's it's a
pleasure to be near them so it's like
another gift thank you uh for real
congrats and good luck on the tour